Now, this is great for JSON, but what if we want to grab something else, say,
a sound file. To do that, we need to set the response type of the XMLHttp
request object to arraybuffer and what that will do is specify that it is binary
information rather than text that we can then decode as necessary. What we like
you to do is create another XMLHttp request but this time we're going to
request "bg_menu.ogg", a sound file and set the response type
to arraybuffer. Now, we've already created the on load function for you to use. Don't worry if
you don't understand any of this. We'll be going over this in more detail later
in the sound unit. For right now, your job is just to fire off the XMLHttp
request.